we're told that one month the ratio of
indoor to outdoor play times for yusuf's
class was two to three
they had 30 total play times
how many of the play times were indoors
how many were outdoors pause this video
and see if you can figure that out
all right now let's work through this
together and i'm going to figure this
out by setting up a little bit of a
table
so we have our indoor
indoor play times
i'll write it out play
times
we have our outdoor play times
outdoor
play
times
then we have our total play times
total
play
times
and then let me set up a table here as
promised
and then i'm going to set up two columns
here
so the first column is going to concern
itself with the ratios so this is the
original
original ratio
and here we're going to put the actual
counts
actual counts
so what information do we know
we know that the ratio of indoor to
outdoor is two
to three so the ratio of indoor to
outdoor is two
to three and then we can also think
about what would be the ratio of either
of these to total play times
well for every two indoor play times
there are three outdoor play times that
means for every two indoor play times
there are five total play times or for
every three outdoor play times there are
five total play times
and now let's think about what we know
about the actual counts they tell us
that there was a 30 total actual play
times so this is the actual number is
30. now this is useful because now we
can think about how do we go from the
original ratios to the actual counts if
we take the total we notice that we are
multiplying by six
so to maintain the ratios we would want
to multiply everything by six so if you
multiply this by 6 you're going to have
12 actual indoor play times and if you
multiply this by 6 you're going to have
18 actual outdoor play times and notice
the ratio still holds up
2 is to 3 as 12 is to 18 or 2 is to 5 as
12 is to 30.
and so there we have it we know how many
of the play times were indoors 12 and
how many were outdoors 18.